nancy pelosi's january 6 commission
kicked off yesterday
with a star performance from one of the
two liberal republicans
who agreed to sit on the otherwise
entirely democrat panel
ladies and gentlemen without further ado
adam kinzinger
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
to my colleagues on the committee
thank you to our witnesses uh i never
expected a day to be
quite as emotional for me as it has been
i've talked to
a number of you and gotten to know you
i think it's important to tell you right
now though
you guys may like individually feel a
little broken
you guys all talk about the effects you
have to deal with and
you know you talk about the impact of
that day
but you guys won
you guys held
you know democracies are not defined
by our bad days
we're defined by how we come back from
bad bad days
how we take accountability for that
and for all the overheated rhetoric
surrounding this committee
our mission is very simple let's define
the truth
and it's to ensure accountability encore
encore mr i've got to wipe a tear from
my eye for reaction
to kinzinger's whining we turn as usual
to don
corleone you can act like a man
what's the matter with you is this how
you turn down a hollywood binocular that
cries like a woman what can i do
what can i do
thank you ridiculous that is ridiculous
kinzinger's statements were ridiculous
but his womanish clown show was the role
to which court jester conservatives such
as he are best suited in our national
drama
today you guys you today you
adam ginziger really he didn't he didn't
surprise anyone with his performance
least of all himself i'm sure he was
practicing that one in the mirror like
any ham actor about to get the hook
but it is worth pointing out that not
only were the
the tiers preposterous but the
statements that he made were
preposterous as well he said that
the capital incident in january was an
insurrection
it was not an insurrection the the way
that we know
in part that this was not it or here's
some evidence that this was not an
insurrection
the weight of the federal government
right now is
trying to prosecute anyone who was in
any way involved in that day it's not
like blm where they all get off the hook
or most of them get off the hook
everyone is trying to prosecute these
guys to the fullest extent of the law
and yet no one is being charged with
seditious conspiracy
no one is being charged with the crimes
associated with insurrection
they're being charged with criminal
trespassing they're being charged with
all sorts of things like
property damage theft but they're not
being charged
with sedition because the feds can't
prove that it was an insurrection
because it wasn't
it was a deadly insurrection well it was
deadly
one person was killed in the violence of
that day
it was a trump supporter it was one of
the people who went into the capital
so i get if if you're saying that it was
a deadly insurrection and that's a
terrible thing
then you should be grilling the cops
that you otherwise were praising all day
because a cop killed a trump supporter
that was the only
i know that we were told in the
aftermath by a bunch of liars
in the establishment media and
in the establishment the political
establishment like adam kinzinger and
all of the democrats
we were told that officer brian sicknick
was killed because someone threw a
fire extinguisher in his head that just
wasn't true that was completely made up
he died of natural causes
days later that's what happened no one
else died another person died of a drug
overdose other people died of natural
causes
the only person who died in political
violence was
one of the pro-trump demonstrators
okay this was the worst attack
on our democracy since 1812 the
political commentator yossi gestetner
had a wonderful threat on this the other
day you probably didn't see it on
twitter because i imagine it was
suppressed
he pointed out that the january sixth
insurrection
uh that involved some damage to the
capital no question about it
there have been other attacks on the
capitol it wasn't the worst one since
1812.
in 19 this is just just from his list
from yossi's list
1954 five congressmen were wounded when
four terrorists opened fire in the
visitors area
president carter later commuted their
sentences or reduced their sentences so
that seems worse than january 6. doesn't
it 1971
a bomb planted by a group or person
protesting the vietnam war so this would
have been a left winger
exploded in the senate wing of the
capital caused extensive damage
thankfully no injuries that seems worse
than january 6. november 7th
1983 an explosion tore through the
second floor of the capitol's north wing
that the device blew the door off of
democrat leader robert byrd's office
seems worse than january 6 1998 two
capital police officers
jacob chestnut jr and john gibson died
in the line of duty because an armed
assailant
stormed past the capital security
checkpoint and he made it into the
building where he was shot seems worse
than january 6th
before midnight on 19 in 1915
police responded to the capital where an
explosion caused huge damage to the
senate wing
then in october of 2018 hundreds of
leftists stormed the u.s senate building
during the work of confirming a supreme
court justice
uh 302 people were arrested by capitol
hill police
no people were last arrested by the
federal government and then last year
in the summer of hate in 2020 when blm
was burning down the country
the president and his family were rushed
to the white house bunker
as insurrectionists i get you got to use
the term right you got
if you're going to use the term for the
horn guys certainly you need to use the
term for the people who stormed the
white house
scaled the fence and 60 secret service
agents were wounded
in the process 11 of them needing
hospitalization
for defending the white house the horn
guy comes in the smiley guy steals
pelosi's podium that was the worst
insurrection in history
but just months prior people stormed the
white house and wound 60 secret service
agents 11 of them
sent to the hospital that was nothing
that truly you probably didn't even hear
about that
or you heard very little or all you
heard from the media were people making
fun of president trump for going into
the bunker
so i just don't want to hear it i don't
want to hear it i never want to hear
another word
about january 6th it's compared
to other attacks that you've never even
heard of they didn't even make the news
really or they are not they don't remain
in the public consciousness
what happened on january 6th was
relatively insignificant
hey i'm glad you liked that clip i
really it
warms my heart now you get the whole
show you can get the whole show
on spotify apple podcasts google play
wherever you get your podcasts
the show is the michael knowles show the
episode is the january 6th commission
clown show
head on don't be an adam kinzinger go on
head on over there do it right now
you can also get my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds see
you next time